no Russian president has done this since
World War II we need to formalize this
regime already within the framework of
the Russian legislation therefore I
signed a decree on the introduction of
Martial law in these four entities of
the Russian Federation it will be
immediately sent to the Federation
Council for approval
Vladimir Putin's orders echoed by his
puppet leaders in Ukraine confirming
martial law had been imposed
the move tightens Russia's grip in areas
of Ukraine it's illegally annexed today
it moved thousands more civilians in the
south of occupied Ukraine that followed
this revealing admission from Putin's
new Commander about Fresh Military
setbacks in the same region
our further actions and plans regarding
the city of Hassan itself will depend on
the military tactic situation at hand I
will say this again it is already very
difficult as of today
each time Putin's face setbacks he's
taken action to appear strong annexation
and mobilization after Retreats by
Russian forces
a wave of drone attacks after a key
bridge was sabotaged and now martial law
but there's a danger in this for Putin
he's called this a special military
operation in Ukraine so that Russians
feel it's remote and far away but first
with mobilization are now dusting down
laws designed for use only in war it's
beginning to feel very different
what was sold as a limited operation is
now feeling bigger than that that could
be a growing problem for Vladimir Putin
Dominic wagorn Sky News Moscow